the tournament of power was announced to
entertain the Lords of everything the
two zenos a battle royale that will
contain 10 representative fighters from
eight other universes but what if I told
you that this was all a fix this is my
theory and how I would write the
tournament of powers ending as it
currently stands Universe 7 has four
Fighters remaining but for the sake of
this video we are assuming that Android
17 is inconsequential and therefore will
be eliminated within an episode or two
sorry 17 you're done good buddy but this
is the big boys table so why don't you
go and so with that we have firefighters
remaining representing Universe 11 we
have toppo with all of his Newfound God
destruction powers and of course let's
not forget jiren but more importantly
Universe 7 has Goku Vegeta and Frieza so
how does this tournament come to an end
well right now we have Frieza left
unconscious at the edge of the Arena
Goku is facing off against jiren and as
we saw in certain previews Vegeta will
be facing top bow and Vegeta will defeat
toppo this is my claim right now I'm
putting it out there while the manga and
the anime don't seem to be following the
same details they do tend to have more
similarities than many might think for
ages it was thought that tapping into
the red Super Saiyan God form was
exclusive to the manga but in episode
104 Goku does just that so assuming that
in a broad character Arc sense the manga
follows similar lines to the anime we
can take a look at this scene from
chapter 27 in which both Vegeta and
beerus have a sparring match and as the
fight concludes beerus remarks that
Vegeta could be a contender for God of
destruction in Another Universe this
insinuates that other universes have
weaker gods of Destruction but do you
know who else was a contender for God of
destruction none other than toppo Vegeta
needs to see this Arc through by besting
toppo now it won't be easy he may even
sustain a mortal injury in fact I assume
he will needless to say I fully expect
him to be out of commission but not
quite eliminated this leaves Universe 11
with one remaining fighter jiren and so
the pieces are in place this is the
final battle Goku vs jiren I expect this
fight when it does come around because
let's face it it's gonna come around to
be incredible Goku going all out with
greater control of ultra Instinct
forcing jiren to take things seriously
yes please the battle rages on however
Goku still isn't enough to stand against
jiren and as universal 11's final
fighter is about to deal the final blow
Vegeta fires a final flash blind
sighting jiren a direct clean hit jiren
is hurt with the thoughts of Kaaba Bulma
Trunks and his newborn baby in his mind
Vegeta just manages to scrap enough
energy together as the shot lands on
jiren Vegeta gives a knowing smirk to
Goku before he falls to the floor
motionless he's done in this moment I
fully expect Vegeta to be eliminated by
jiren or be outed due to in injury Goku
in this instance manages to regroup
thanks to the distraction from Vegeta
feeling the threat of defeat looming
over his head Goku charges up to ultra
Instinct for one last flurry one final
effort against an injured jiren the gray
for the first time the tournament jiren
is in trouble Goku has him on the ropes
as he bombards the gray with a flurry of
connecting blows causing him to crash
into a wall this is Goku's last chance
he begins to chant Ka May ha May
suddenly without warning just as Goku
was to unleash an enormous Kamehameha a
strange flash of light envelops our
screens when the flash subsides a sudden
Deja Vu crosses all of her Collective
Minds we find ourselves back in the
moment Vegeta threw caution to the wind
and fired that Final Flash however the
difference this time jiren Dodges having
not sustained that injury jiren quickly
eliminates Vegeta and presses the attack
on Goku but how could this happen
temporal do-over Zeno while massively
powerful doesn't know much about
anything he is truly a neutral force in
the universe his window into the lives
and goings on around the Multiverse is
the grand priest in chapter 28 of the
manga Zeno asked the grand priest how
the universes are doing to which he
reports that Universe 1 is in the lead
Universe 12 has shown rapid growth and
that there hasn't been much change with
the others and that some of them might
have even gone down slightly how is this
measured this growth this Improvement my
theory is that this is the grand
priest's measuring stick the grand
priest knows that he who controls Zeno
controls reality and he controls that
little football-headed shortstock Zeto
asked a question and boom the grand
priest is Zeno's answer he has his own
measure of morality he makes the rules
and he is The Mastermind behind this
entire propaganda machine Zeno whether
he knows it or not is being controlled
by the grand priest who are the only
beings permitted to survive the
universe's elimination his children yes
the Angels so neutral are they to
sarcastically joke and satisfyingly
smile when faced with their own
universe's destruction the grand priest
their father is the Puppet Master but
for the first time things have not gone
according to plan Goku was not supposed
to gain the upper hand over jiren no one
is supposed to gain the upper hand over
jiren this was supposed to be a sure
thing perhaps promised to him by an old
God of destruction on the verge of
retirement but Universe 7 did gain the
upper hand and so in that moment right
before jiren was to be eliminated by
Goku the grand priest performs a
temporal do-over informing jiren of what
was to come so that he would be prepared
having successfully dodged Vegeta's last
ditch Final Flash jiren is once again
free to dominate Goku however all is not
well with one angel whis whis has
demonstrated in the past that he has
been willing to bend the rules on
occasion on top of that he also has
developed a particular fondness for the
earthlings I mean look at his response
to finding out that Goku achieved Ultra
Instinct he's like a proud mother after
hearing his son got accepted to Yale or
something whis notices what has
transpired and with a knowing glare as
Goku is about to be defeated rewinds
time once again informing Goku of what
jiren will do to at least give him a
Fighting Chance this keeps with the
trend that the heroes never win anything
in super without the help of divine
intervention Goku uses this opportunity
to his advantage and delivers a decisive
blow to jiren temporal do-over due to
its large recharge time cannot be used
by the grand priest or whis any longer
both Warriors continue to fight
desperately across the shattered Arena
their Lone Battle cries Echo throughout
the empty stage but again another flash
of light envelops our screens but this
one's different and not entirely
unfamiliar to Goku having carried
himself out of the Heap topple left him
in Frieza releases an enormous death
ball destroying what was left of the
Arena allowing no footholds for Goku and
jiren Frieza is the last one to fall out
of bounds frieza's plan has come to
fruition as the sole survivor to the
torment of power the evil emperor is the
Victor Universe 7 the winners Frieza
announces that he has a wish to make and
on that Cliffhanger Dragon Ball super
would end why because the Dragon Ball
story is not complete yet or at least I
don't think it is what do you guys think
of my ending what would you change let
me know Down Below in the comments I
want to know how you guys think the
series will end I know my theory is a
little out there but I thought it would
be fun nonetheless if you like this
video don't forget to leave a like and
if you want to see more Dragon Ball
analysis maybe try subscribing it's good
karma but that'll do it for this week
I've been totally not mark thank you so
much for watching